what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and promotion for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is ramping up as we have less
than a month now until the movie
releases in theaters i would expect
several more tv spots to come out as
this is typically what marvel studios
does right before the release of the
movies they typically release a lot of
tv spots just to ramp up the hype even
more right before that film comes out
but some people have been asking me if
they will do a final trailer one that's
maybe two minutes long two and a half
minutes long and it's definitely
possible but right now i wouldn't count
on that because they are still trying to
be pretty secretive about what's
actually going to be taking place in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness so i would expect some tv spots
with some new footage but i wouldn't
expect a final trailer which is great
because this movie is going to be packed
full of surprises now we know some of
them like professor xavier showing up
and the illuminati but some we don't
know for example paul bettany today kind
of teased a little bit about him being
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and i think he might actually be
a key to bringing wanda back from being
evil we know she becomes evil in this
movie whether that she's possessed or
being influenced by the darkhold
whatever it is i think vision coming
back could actually bring her back from
that dark side so to speak which is what
we're going to be talking about today
and if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel news now if you're
watching this video you're probably
really excited for doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness and i'm hoping
that you've seen one division if you
haven't seen one division before doctor
strange two comes out please watch that
series it's incredible and you need to
watch that to know what is happening
here and spoiler alert because i'm about
to talk about it now there's many
important things about one division like
wanda and visions kids billy and tommy
wanda discovering that she is the
scarlet witch her coming across the
darkhold and a new vision was created
white vision and we're hoping that
multiverse of madness might actually
answer a question that we had during one
of vision which of course was where the
heck did white vision go he kind of just
took off and marvel studios has really
kept a tight lid on where he could have
possibly gone and if he's going to come
back but we know marvel studios
everything that they do pretty much has
a plan so why introduce this other
vision and have him leave to not come
back at some point in time especially if
you consider that our main vision is
really gone like really gone but the
white vision the new vision could be
coming back and it is possible that our
real vision did imprint some type of
memories from the real visions past with
wanda with the kids with everything and
maybe this one could actually slowly
turn into the real vision again after
all vision is an android in theory if
you just implant him with the same
memories he could be the same person and
maybe we could see that happen in doctor
strange too as paul bettany is kind of
teased that he might be in it now i
would be really shocked if paul bettany
wasn't in it at all yes it's a doctor
strange movie but it's very much a
wandem movie as well it's pretty much
half and half at this point and vision
is an extremely important part of wanda
and if we're telling the story of wanda
he should be in it so i'm expecting a
flashback or an illusion or of course
going into another universe and seeing a
different version of vision perhaps
there's a different version of him that
is actually human like a full-on human
but of course we'll have to be aware
well wanda will have to be aware because
there's probably another version of him
that is the ultron vision and is
probably pretty evil pretty much what we
saw and what if but here's what paul
bettany has been saying about possibly
appearing in multiverse of madness paul
bettany recently went on the late show
with stephen colbert and was asked if he
would be making an appearance in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and this is what he said this is a
really great question and again i said i
was going to be entirely honest with you
you're asking if am i in doctor strange
yes no yes no yes no i don't know am i
what do you think i can neither confirm
nor deny rumors that i am and said and
after mentioned doctor strange so he's
playing it extremely coy he's having fun
with it because well he really toyed
with us with one division when he said
that he's going to be in a final scene
with somebody that he's always wanted to
act with we were expecting somebody huge
like patrick stewart but it ended up
being himself and i think he knows that
he made a lot of people mad there so i
think he's being pretty cautious with
what he is saying here but again let's
be honest it would be really weird if he
actually wasn't in the movie at least a
little bit i mean we have so many people
that are going to be in this movie x-men
hopefully fantastic four a lot of
different variants of different
characters heck patrick stewart is
coming back to play professor x and he
said that he laid that character to rest
and of course there's rumors like
deadpool and perhaps some of the x-force
could be coming as well there's so much
happening in this film that it wouldn't
make sense to not have paul bettany in
it he should be in the movie in some way
shape or form the only questions are
which vision is it going to be and how
is he exactly going to return but the
first question kind of has a big part in
the play in the second question because
if the original vision returns the
question of how does vision return is a
lot more complicated but if it's the
white vision that we saw that simply
just took off at the end of one division
well the how is pretty simple he simply
returns he decides to come back and seek
out wanda for whatever reason now again
it looked like vision kind of implanted
some memories inside of him or woke them
up inside of him and perhaps this could
actually be a key to getting wanda to
kind of come back from kind of going on
this killing rampage of looking for her
kids now we know that wanda is going to
be the main villain of this film and we
know that she's gonna kill a lot of
people we've seen recently new footage
of her being very very bloody she's even
holding an ultron bot head in her hand
using magic and she crushes it so we 100
know that she attacks the illuminati now
and probably kills them all
unfortunately and it looks like doctor
strange pretty much has his hands full
as well dealing with some of his other
variants and other villains and wanda is
the scarlet witch the most powerful
being in the universe at this point and
to top it all off she could be possessed
by the darkhold we've already seen some
demons being summoned that looked a lot
like c'thun perhaps c'thun is kind of
controlling her via the darkhold either
way we know that she is not entirely in
control but she kind of doesn't care
because she just wants to do whatever it
takes to get her kids back so what can
stop her well it would make sense that
her husband if you could call him her
husband since they got married in her
fantasy world but vision the love of her
life could bring her back and talk sense
into her that's typically what he does
that could be a solution to bringing
wanda slash the scarlet witch back or it
could backfire we could see vision die
again she could see through this new
vision that could be returning and say
you're not the real vision you're not my
viz the hell with you i'm destroying you
you're just another ultron bot to me
because it could also activate some
pretty bad memories of when sword tried
to essentially capture her and take her
out she could view white vision as a
weapon of sword still and not something
that could actually help her but again
we know that marvel typically has a plan
for everything that they do so why did
white vision randomly disappear in the
finale of one division what is their
master plan for him and could we
possibly see him return in multiverse of
madness i think we're gonna see paul
bettany in this film no matter what i
think it wouldn't make sense if we
didn't whether that's a flashback or
whatever the question is in what
capacity are we going to see him could
it be the original viz or could it be
the new white viz and could he be kind
of wanda's savior in this film because i
truly believe that they're not going to
be able to defeat the scarlet witch i
think she's going to have to snap out of
it and kind of come to her senses and
essentially beat herself whether that's
her waking up and saying i'm so sorry
for everything i did lock me up or she
goes away and says you'll never see me
again or it comes down to her fighting
possibly c'thun or another variant of
her that could be influencing her so
that she can finally be free be free
over the curse of the dark hole to be
free of the pain that she's had this
whole entire time either way i think
there's going to be a wanda versus wanda
confrontation and our wanda will
probably end up being at least somewhat
good by the end of this film we'll have
to wait and see but fortunately not much
longer to wait in the meantime let me
know if you think vision will return in
multiverse of madness let me know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]